in the last video we were able to get a
pretty good sense about how large of an
x we should cut out of each corner in
order to maximize our volume and we did
this graphically what i want to do in
this video is use some of our calculus
tools to see if we can come up with the
same or maybe even a better result so to
do that i'm going to have to figure out
the critical points of our volume as a
function of x and to do that i need to
take the derivative of the volume so let
me do that and before i even do that
it'll simplify things so i don't have to
use some the product rule in some way
and then have to simplify that let me
just multiply this expression out so
let's rewrite volume as a function of x
is equal to and i'll write it all in
yellow
so it's going to be x times i'll
multiply these two binomials first so 20
times 30 is 600
then i have 20 times negative 2x which
is negative 40x that i have negative 2x
times 30 which is negative
60x and then i have negative 2x times
negative 2x which is positive
4 x squared so this part over here
simplifies and i can change the order to
4 x squared minus 100x minus 100x
plus 600. i just switched the order in
which i'm writing them so that's that
and so i can rewrite the volume of x as
being equal to x times all of this
business which is let me make sure i
have enough space let me do a little
higher which is equal to
4 x to the third power minus 100
x squared plus 600x
that'll be pretty straightforward to
take the derivative so let's say that v
prime of x
v prime of x is going to be equal to i
just have to use the power rule multiple
times so 4 times 3 is 12
x to the 3 minus 1 power 12x squared
minus 200 times x to the first power
which is just x
plus
plus
600
and so now we just have to figure out
when this is equal to zero so we have to
figure out when 12 x squared minus 200 x
plus 600 is equal to zero what x values
gets my derivative to be equal to zero
when is my slope equal to zero
i could also look for critical points
where the derivative is undefined but
this this derivative is defined
especially throughout my the my domain
of x that i care about between x's
between 0 and 10.
so i could try to factor this or try to
simplify this a little bit but i'm just
going to cut to the chase and try to use
the quadratic formula here so this is
the x's that satisfy this is going to be
x is going to be equal to
so negative b
so it's 200
negative negative 200 is positive 200
plus or minus the square root
of b squared
which is negative 200 squared so i could
just write that as 200 squared it
doesn't matter if it's negative 200
squared or 200 squared i'm going to get
the same value
so
let me give myself some more space so
negative 200 squared well that's going
to be four
with four zeros one two three four so
that's going to be forty thousand
minus four ac
so minus four
times
12
12 times 600 i still didn't give myself
enough space times
600
all of that over
2 times a so all of that over 24 and
i'll take it take out the calculator
again to try to calculate this so let me
get out of graphing mode
all right so first i'll try when i add
when i add the radical so i'm going to
get 200
200
plus
the square root of
40 000.
i could have just written that
i could have just written that as 200
squared but that's fine 40 000
minus 4 times 12
times 600
times 600
and i get
305 which i then need to divide by 24
which i'll divide by 24 and i get
12.74 so one of my possible x's so it
equals 12.74
and now let me do the situation where i
subtract what i had in the radical sign
so let me get my calculator back and so
now let me do 200
i probably could have done this slightly
more efficiently but this is fine
minus the square root of
forty thousand one two three
minus
four times 12
times 600
and i get that's just the numerator and
then i'm going to divide that by 24
divide that by 24 and i get 3.92
did i do that right 200 minus 40 000
minus 4 times 12 times 600 although all
of that divided by 24 my previous answer
divided by 24 gives me 3.92
so it's 12.74 or
3.92 now which of these can i use
well 12 point x equals 12.74 is outside
of our outside of our valid values for x
if x was equal to 12.74 we would cut
past we would completely cut pat the x's
would start to overlap with each other
so x cannot be
12.74 so we get a critical point at x is
equal to 3.92 and you could look at the
graph that you could say oh look that
looks like a maximum value
but if you didn't have the graph at your
disposal you can then do the second
derivative test and say hey are we
concave upwards or concave downwards
when x is equal to 3.92
well in order to do the second
derivative test you have to figure out
what the second derivative is so let's
do that v prime prime of x is going to
be equal to is going to be equal to 24 x
24 times x to the first
minus 200
minus
minus 200
and you can just look at inspection that
this number right over here is less than
4 so this thing right over here is going
to be less than 100 you subtract
you subtract 200 so we can write the
second derivative at 3.92 is going to be
less than zero you can figure out what
the net the exact value is if you like
so because this is less than zero we are
concave downwards
concave
downwards another way of saying it is
that the slope is
the slope is decreasing the entire time
concave downwards when the slope is
decreasing the entire time our shape
looks like that the slope could start
off high lower lower gets to zero even
lower lower lower and we even saw that
on the graph right over here and since
it's concave downwards that implies that
our critical point that sits where or
during where the interval is concave
downward that critical point is a local
maximum
is
is a maximum so this is the x value at
which our function attains our maximum
now what what is that maximum value well
we could type that back in into our
original expression for volume to figure
what that is so let's figure out what
the volume
when we get to 3.92
is equal to what is our maximum volume
so get the calculator back out and i
could use we it's obviously roughly 3.92
i could use this exact value actually
let's well i'll just use 3.92 to get a
rough sense of what our maximum value is
our maximum volume so it'll be
3.92
3.92 i'll just use this this expression
for the volume as a function of x 3.92
times times 20
minus 2 times 3.92
times
30
30
minus
2 times 3.92
gives us and we deserve a drum roll now
gives us 1056.3
so 1056.
which is a higher volume than we got
when we just inspected it graphically we
probably could have gotten a little bit
more precise if we zoomed in some and
then we would have gotten a little bit
better of an answer but there you have
it analytically we were able to actually
get an even better answer than we were
able to do at least on that first pass
graphically